today I visited the area which is known
as Little Rome because there are so many
Roman Catholics there to hear firsthand
what happened this is st. Sebastian
church in negombo it is one of six
locations that were hit there were three
churches and three hotels hitting the
first wave of suicide bombings too later
but it's were than most people died and
you can see why if we look at the damage
that was done by a massive blast a
suicide bomb one bomber
setting off a device that has blown the
roof off the building it's blowing the
windows out and inside the building the
walls are spattered with shrapnel that
has punctured the plaster roof the walls
right across that back wall and there's
blood and flesh spattered across the
walls as well and inside we think there
are scenes of crime officers certainly
Sri Lankan officials in there surveying
the damage now I talked earlier to a
local journalist for sad martyr killer
who told me what he heard he was at home
he heard the blast just before 9 o'clock
in the morning what he heard and then
what he saw when he came here for the
aftermath immediately after that bomb
went off my mommy got me people were
covered in blood and running all around
people around this area were trying to
help and take them to hospital as soon
as possible I was so confused I forgot
to take my camera from the bike
I started videoing the scene from my
phone I saw people had fallen everywhere
it's hard to describe but a single
person without injury from the blast
there were 1200 people inside the church
they were preparing for Easter Sunday
service a service that celebrates
resurrection and hope and instead they
were massacred and you can see some of
the clothes that's been sort of put
together now but would have been
discarded in a hurry as people fled from
the massacre after that bomb went off
you can only imagine the scene and the
seconds and minutes after that blast as
Franco of course is no stranger to
sectarian violence the civil war here
that ended 10 years ago killed tens of
thousands of people lasted decades this
is not thought to be a return to that
kind of sectarian violence not Tamil
Tigers or Tamil separatists so far it's
being blamed on Islamists but there is a
fear that this could be the country
returning back to terrorist violence at
least and I spoke earlier to Ram Chandra
Menaka who's a minister in the
government and I put that to him I asked
him whether he was worried that those 10
years of karma relative peace had now
been shattered I don't know why
terrorists people the the this brutal
terrorist groups why they found why why
the monitor and by the Select alicante -
so the scene now is is one of people
local people just trying to come to
terms I think with what has happened
here nuns walking through the forecourt
of the church as we're saying people
inside surveying the damage and we're
told that later on today they're
preparing for some of those bodies to be
brought here and to be buried in the
burial ground and you have to bear in
mind this is just one church of three
that were damaged destroyed like this in
the first wave of the suicide glass and
so many other people killed mourning
their relatives or in hospital fighting
for their lives seriously injured by
terrible bomb blast injuries